the number of branches of an oak tree
and a birch tree since 1950 are
represented by the following tables so
for the oak tree we see when time equals
zero has 34 branches after three years
it has 46 branches so on and so forth
and the birch tree they give a similar
data at the beginning has eight branches
in ten years has 33 branches and they
give us all of that and what I want to
think about in this video is how should
we model these if we want to model these
with functions and the choices we'll
give ourselves there are other options
but the choices we'll give ourselves in
this video are linear and linear versus
exponential functions which of these are
going to be better for modeling for
modeling these this this data so let's
first look at the oak tree and the key
to realization is whenever have a fixed
increase in time so each of these steps
this is plus three years so it's a fixed
increase in time what happens to my
number of branches this is going to be a
fixed change in which or roughly a fixed
change in which case a linear model
might be good or is it going to be a
change that's dependent on where we were
so what am I talking about so 34 to 46
that is plus 12 46 to 59 is plus 13 59
270 is plus 11 70 to 80 2 is plus 12 and
so at first you might say well hey this
this isn't an exactly fixed change these
numbers they seem to average right
around 12 but when you're looking at
real-world data you're never going to
get something that is exact the models
are just going to give us a good fit are
going to give us a good approximation of
the behavior of the number of branches
over time for me this is pretty close to
a constant 12 branches a year so I would
construct a linear model here I would
say here branches as a function of time
let me be clear this isn't 12 branches
per year this is 12 branches every three
years 12 this is 13 branches over three
years this was 11 branches every three
years we're going to average twelve
branches over three
years so the number of branches we have
we're going to start at 34 branches and
then - with 12 branches every three
years that's four branches every or
esterday plus four branches every year
and you could test this out B of zero is
going to give us thirty four branches B
of twelve let's just really test out the
extreme part of the model B of twelve is
going to be 34 plus 48 which is equal to
which is equal to 82 so this model works
quite well it's going to have a couple
of places we're sad exactly exactly
fitting the data but it fits it quite
quite well and so this is a linear model
so this one is linear now let's look at
the birch tree so time equals zero so
fix change in time let me the wrong
layer alright so we have a fixed change
in time every time we are moving into
the future a decade let's see our change
in branches we go from 8 to 33 so what
is that that is plus 25 branches then we
go from 33 to 128 well that's way more
than 25 branches that's going to be what
5 less than 5 less than 100 so that's
going to be plus 95 branches so this
clearly is not a linear model and so
let's think in terms of an exponential
model how much you have to multiply to
go from I do that right 128 - yeah if it
was 133 then it would be 100 it's 5 less
than that yep okay so now let's think
about it in terms of an exponential
model in terms of the next exponential
model we care what would we have to
multiply for each for each step so if we
have a constant step in time what do we
multiply for are how much we increase
our branches so to go to 8 - 33
that'll be approximately it's going to
be approximately 4 it's going to be a
little bit more than 4 33 to 128 well
that's going to be a little bit less
than 4 but it's approximately 4 33 times
four be 132 so we're close 128 to 512
that's
exactly four right that's exactly 120
times four is four eighty plus
thirty-two yep
that is exactly 4 so times four and so
it looks like we keep we keep
multiplying by four every ten years that
go by so one way one way to think about
it is we could say here B of T the
branches of T our initial condition our
initial state is eight and now we could
say our common factor is four take is
four but if we want t to be in years
well that every 10 years we multiply by
a factor of four so T has to go to ten
before we increase the exponent to one
or has to go to 20 until this exponent
becomes 2 so 8 times 4 to the T over 10
power seems like a pretty good pretty
good
model and you could even verify this for
yourself if you like try out what B of
30 is going to be B of 30 would be 8
times 4 to the 30 divided by 10 to the
third power and what is that going to be
that's going to be 4 to the 3rd is 64 64
8 times 64 is it's 480 plus 32 it is 512
so then once again this exponential
model this exponential model for this
data it does a pretty good job